pour gaëtan c'est le grand jour six ans
qu'ils attendaient ça
six nations de paris dans quelques
heures il va se mettre à nu
racontez ce fameux soir d'automne
j'ai tellement refait cette journée dans
la tête que du mal à réaliser que c'est
quand même le jour qui le hante depuis
quand même déjà de longues semaines donc
jusqu'ici jusqu'ici tout va bien
comme de nombreuses victimes galtes ans
a choisi se constituer partie civile et
de témoigner une évidence pour lui
je crois que j'attends rien des prévenus
clairement
j'accueillerai éventuellement une forme
de rédemption quelles qu'elles soient et
quelle quelle forme allait mais en tout
cas moi j'attends rien de
particulièrement quoi ça serait ça
serait mentir j'attends juste que la
justice fasse son travail et qu'elle
puisse agir sereinement comme elle je
trouve qu elle le fait depuis le début
dans quelques minutes il va prendre la
parole pour une seule chose par les
décrire le mâle féroce qui le dévore
[Musique]
ego pour se préparer gaëtan avalent des
kilomètres
presque chaque jour le même rituel des
heures de course dans la campagne
nivernaise
son havre de paix
la course à pied c'est
cesser c'est vraiment une des solutions
que j'ai trouvé pour pour vivre après
quoi et avec
c'est vraiment l'endroit idoine pour se
retrouver avec soi et puis uniquement
avec soin et oublier tout le reste quoi
donc c'est vrai que c'est une un milieu
qui
y répondent vraiment à mes besoins ce
moment-là corps et de style ans de calme
oui clairement clairement le à la une
cette vertu de makiese et puis d'être de
me renvoyer une image belle quand même
quoi donc de deux mètres du but dans la
vie
parce qu'en ville c'est plus compliqué à
chaque sortie les angoisses reviennent
peur de la foule peur des lieux publics
c'est surtout le la promiscuité avec les
gens vous savez quand on se quand on
était très proches les uns des autres
quand on sent le souffle de l'autre par
exemple ou canton on se touche quoi ça
c'est quelque chose qui est proprement
insupportable donc c'est vrai que je
fuis clairement les endroits où il ya
trop de monde
après les attentats le jeune professeur
s'est remis au travail il est
aujourd'hui directeur d'école
les enfants une bouée de sauvetage pour
lui
c'est toujours très important je peux
entendre leurs rires et puis l'heure
leur enthousiasme c'est c'est vraiment
un moteur personnel mois pour beaucoup
ça m'a permis de rester comme ça à
flottaison et puis d'être
de pouvoir rebondir après pour plus tard
c'est ce qui m'a vraiment maintenu quoi
avec les vivants quoi
mais aujourd'hui il quitte sa petite
cour d'école pour l'immense salle
d'audience du palais de justice de paris
1700 parties civiles 330 avocat quatorze
accusés un procès hors norme pour des
attentats qui ont endeuillé la france
entière
130 morts au stade de france sur les
terrasses et au bataclan
[Musique]
ce soir là gaëtan et dans la fosse où
j'ai distingué un des terroristes qui
commençait à lui mais la faim qui ont
commencé à tirer et en fait dans un
premier mouvement de foule j'ai été
complètement
bousculé projeté au sol et une personne
s est littéralement
misé sur moi un personnage est imposante
qui me dit attention réservé charge
nouvelle salve là cette fois je sens une
sorte de blast un peu sur moi et je vous
jure fait jeu je comprends qu'il va
mourir en fait sur moi quoi ce qu'il
vient de se prendre une balle et en fait
ils commencent à se vider de son sang
militairement sur moi donc là je suis je
prends conscience que ce qui me coule
dans l'oreille c'est ces deux sont un
autre clairement il m'a sauvé la vie de
foi jeudi parce qu'il m'a sauvé la vie
en prenant la balle qui m'était destinée
et puis surtout je pense que comme
j'étais couvert d'un gîte et couvert de
sang tout le monde pensait que j'étais
mort quoi deux heures de terreur
résumé en 12 minutes devant la cour et à
la sortie le soulagement
j'ai le sentiment d'avoir dit ce que je
voulais dire je crois que c'était
vraiment ce que j'avais voulu j'avais
des appréhensions c'est de voir certains
regrets en dix ans à gérer j'ai pas
abordées telles questions tel sujet
finalement voilà que ça a été
j'ai balayé tout ce que tous les sujets
je voulais aborder donc ça c'était le
sentiment du devoir accompli
[Musique]
une page qui se tourne avec de nouveaux
projets est un symbole fort retourner
bientôt au bataclan
j'ai enfin trouvé le concert idoine pour
me permettre et motorisées et retournez
donc
début décembre je vais faire une date au
bataclan je pense que c'est le bon
timing
un truc un peu comme sa circulaire
donc mois de novembre plus qu'il ya
plein de symboles qui font que je fais
j'attends cette date avec une certaine
impatience qu'on sens d'une certaine
angoisse évidemment mais voilà je pense
que je suis prêt retourner quoi car non
mais cette fois le fan de musique ira
voir un concert de rap
car depuis cette soirée là impossible
pour lui d'y écouter du rock
[Musique]